thank you so I'll be talking about
modeling mutational patterns from two
original data I'm going to start again
by saying that tumors of different
patients are heterogeneous so here you
see a matrix where rows are jeans and
columns are patients from different
cancers and the different cancers are
indicated by colors and so okay you can
see that there are few genes like tp53
which are very frequently mutated so
there's no doubt that they make they
have a lot of impact on development of
cancer a few other genes can be
clustered though so these are indicated
in colors can be clustered with together
with the with the cancers so they can be
thought of is responsible for these
cancers but for a lot of genes we cannot
say whether they are important for a
specific cancer or not and these are
these ones in gray very infrequently
mutated okay so now that the first
question is the first important question
that we ask is which mutations are
drivers and which are passengers so this
is by standard approaches assessed by
this frequency of mutations but as I
said this doesn't always work or by
putting these genes and functional or
network context by enrichment in non
pathways or by looking at sets of genes
and Dame their mutations and by this
finding mutated pathways de novo okay
and now a second question may be even
more important one is which of these
mutated genes could be exploited for
cancer therapy and now the first obvious
answer to that question is well the
drivers the ones still with the answer
to the first question right the ones
very important should be maybe targeted
but another answer which is maybe even
more and if
efficient approach to cancer therapy is
a synthetic lethal partners of mutated
genes and not necessarily only driver
genes but any genes that are mutated in
cancer patients okay and the reason why
these two items are in red is because
first of all I will be talking about
them today and second of all because
both of these exhibits mutually
exclusive ad patterns in tumor genomic
data ok so again what are mutually
exclusive patterns of cancer mutations
and so you can see such patterns when
you in in in matrices of gene mutations
where you arrange on the one side the
tumors and jeans on the others who hear
the rows and the columns and you you see
this mutual exclusivity when at most one
mutation in the gene set occurs / tumor
so those tumors that show this these
with this mutual exclusivity we say they
are covered by a mutual exclusivity and
if we see violation to that strict
definition then we say we have impurity
of mutual exclusive patent ok so that
was always actually observed a long time
ago that a cancer pathways show this
mutually exclusive patterns in tumor
genomic data ok but why so I'm going to
try to explain why do actually dis
cancer pathways show mutual exclusivity
so I prepared the small an invention to
explain this for you ok so imagine you
are given a tumor I and other specific
point in time genes in some cancer
pathway are not mutated in the end the
cells in this tumor have some fitness
which is indicated by this red arrow and
I imagine that to one of these genes in
the
third pathway gets mutated and then we
make an assumption if you mutate one
gene in the pathway the entire pathway
is off ok so then because it's cancer
pathway fitness of such a cell where
this happens increases and then because
of the fitness increase this mutation in
gene one fixates in the population of
cells of this tumor so then when we take
this tumor and we sequence the tumor we
can see this mutation in g1 into more I
ok but if we now had in any other cell
after that mutations in additional genes
there is because the pathway was already
off there is no or slight fitness
increase so these mutations do not fix
it in the population and we don't see
them ok now just to complete the
animation if we imagine another tumor to
merge a and another gene in the CAF
cancer pathway mutates first we get the
fitness increased pathways off and the
this first gingy to in this case gets
fixated and gets mutated and the other
ones not okay right so ok so so this is
how the cancer pathways show mutually
exclusive patterns we get that already
and now a bunch of different groups
different studies started exploiting
this phenomenon the other way around so
they started looking for mutually
exclusive pathways in the data and
and proposed cancer pathway can't see
past a hypothesis okay so because there
is such a lot of these different studies
that I if I would cite all of them I it
would get me out of my slide space so i
decided i'm just going to cite people
who are in this room so and so there was
a lot of papers with the lysosome of
this as the first author of and then
fabula the first offer of course been
Raphael around there there is paper from
today's usuki metal paper from taras up
to discuss group and there's also our
company our mutual exclusivity come from
with papers which originated from Nico's
group and I'm going to briefly cover two
of them here so oh okay so the first
paper that we published on this this was
our approach mu X and this motivation
for that approach was that we wanted to
propose a regardless statistical model
that could provide the significance
estimation for these mutual exclusivity
patterns we also thought that that T a
lot of mutual exclusivity patterns that
were reported in the literature they
seemed to us unbalanced so with one gene
highly dominating the entire pattern
which seemed biologically not really
relevant and then we also wanted to take
into account the fact that in in this
tumor sequencing data you have a lot of
false negative and false positive
mutations so then we propose this
generative process models a model which
can be illustrated in such steps so
first you choose that the patients which
should be covered by their which which
are covered by the mutual exclusivity
pattern with some rate lambda and then
we have we add impurity with rate Sigma
and then we have errors false positives
and false negatives and the graphical
representation of what model is is here
we have
hidden variables one for their coverage
of patients and 14 for choosing which
gene should be actually mutually
exclusive in a covered patient and that
specifically as indicated here in the
brackets that variable and forced
balanced patterns so it would strongly
enforced that each gene can be the
single mutually exclusive limited gene
with equal probability okay okay and
then we we had a significance in this
model was computed by if I likelihood
ratio test where the the the null model
was simply a model which assumed that
the genes are independent so then we
analyze this modeling we've increased
complexity so we had some efficient
algorithm for elf parameter estimation
with some assumptions and then we showed
that in the full model the parameters
are identifiable but not identifiable in
practice you need basically infinitely
many samples to really reliably estimate
the parameters okay and then there came
a paper from by simona which i would
like to really point to you because i
think it's a very natural approach of
short of representing mutual exclusivity
which has this timing aspect which a lot
of people actually ask for nowadays so
this is our our response to that so we
we have the waiting time too so okay we
say okay every gene gets mutated in
specific time in the tumor evolution
right so there is a waiting time to
alteration of gene I and this waiting
time is a random variable which is
exponentially distributed with some red
rate lambda I and we don't know at which
time point of gene evolution the
diagnostic the diagnosis happens so
there's this observation time which is
also then a random variable and and we
have the denominated we are asking about
mutual exclusivity of two genes
the in dena model the genes are
conditionally independent given of these
of the observation time in these waiting
times and in the mutual exclusivity
model this model is exactly the same as
the null model but now here the jeans
are not conditionally independent and
they were dependence is governed by this
Web mu parameter which which when you
set it to zero then you get to the
nested a null model but if you set it to
one you get perfect mutual exclusivity
and I'm not going to get into details of
that model but just to point you to the
main message servant of that model in
the mutual exclusivity model if we have
this this interesting observation where
you really have only single gene one
gene mutated and the other ones not then
the likelihood of that observation and a
mutual exclusivity model this is
decomposed into two into two terms and
one of them is the is the term which
which is exactly the same as in the null
model so we and we observe so so we say
ok we observed us that single mutation
because it just happened before the
diagnosis and the other one the waiting
time for the other ones is just later
but they would have occurred if we
sampled later ok so that's no mutual
exclusivity but in the mutual
exclusivity case ok we have this we the
other mutations so this one mutation
happens but the other mutations the
mutations of other Jews could have
happened before the observation time but
we we don't see them right so the they
don't fixate so that much is exactly
what this animation that I showed you in
the in the introduction ok so so that's
it about mutual exclusivity which points
to cancer pathways ok and now i'm going
to switch to a completely different
aspect of mutual exclusivity which
points to synthetic lethality which you
saw already in the morning so just to
again put you into into right
on the border of this topic so we say
synthetic lethality if we so there is a
synthetic lethal interaction between DNA
and gene be if mutation of janae gives
your cell survival mutation of gin be
alone gives you sir survival but if you
mutate or if you if you knock out in two
of them you have cellular death so this
has been proposed a long time ago
already that we can harness synthetic
lethal interactions in cancer treatment
and this is because if you in normal
cells if you and if there if there is
interest synthetic lethal interaction
between gene and gene be if you knock
out any of these genes in normal cells
you this normal cells survive but in the
cancer cells one of these genes is
already mutated so if you inhibit the
other one you exploit this genetic
interaction and you have cellular death
specifically of the tumor cells and not
of the normal cells and that a very
famous example for that is the bracha
one or two and part 1 and the part 1
inhibitors are are already around in
exploiting that interaction so okay so
I'm just going to repeat maybe the
discovery of synthetic lethal
interactions is extremely difficult so
the experimental approaches are over
overwhelmed by the combinatorial number
of overall possible purse of human genes
and you know different tissues and so on
so there have been studies with which
focus on one experimental studies which
focus on one prominent cancer gene and
screen for interaction partners of that
one gene or which otherwise limited to
or which live in somehow this testing
input in any other way like for example
just sorry just take testing just
testing DNA repair genes now the
computational there were lots of
different SL prediction computational SL
prediction approaches but the ones that
i want to point you to our
are ones that combine different sources
of evidence from different kinds of data
so so this is an overview from paper
which you have seen already in the
morning by a ton from a 10 groupings
group so the idea is okay we're going to
combine all these different data sets
we're going to mind first for synthetic
aside interactions we're going to get
this concert synthetic lethality network
then maybe add additional patient
information and hopefully predict gene
essentiality run responses and clinical
prognosis okay so one approach I want to
review with them bilu a tile from nature
communications for us from 2013 which
had some someone indirect discovery of
SLE interactions from you know from not
from experimental data but from from a
different data set so they were looking
at evolutionary events of the obesity
building phylogenetic species trees and
they were decorating them with presence
or absence like Jeanne losses or gains
and then from there they were inferring
via machine learning approaches as
symmetric dependence interactions and
then looking for- genetic interactions
between human genes in general not
cancer specific and then they needed
additional data yet additional data that
could pinpoint them to select tumor
specific predictions now what we have
done in our work and of course what you
have seen already from 8 a-8 on today in
the morning other approaches look at
gene mutation expression clinical data
which comes from tumors okay directly
from like TCGA right from directly from
tumor genomic data and is already
tumor-specific so what we have done we
will combine different types of genomic
data point mutations copy number
variants gene expression with survival
and and we were specifically we looked
for mutual exclusivity
confirmation survival data we ranked the
candidate gene pairs accordingly and
then we assigned significance to these
findings using Cox models so so the
first criterion for us for detecting SL
gene purse from the genomic and clinical
data the first criterion for us was of
course this mutual exclusivity so we
looked so we divided the set of tumors
that that we had at hand into four
groups one of the mg one was word the
first in in the pair is me rated only
and they said the g2 would be another
group of tumors where this second gene
is mutated on me and then a third girl
it would be both we're both of them are
mutated at the same time and of course
from the basic definition of synthetic
lethality you expect that if the if t1
and t2 are synthetic lethal then you
want that both group is under
represented in the data given the
frequency of mutations of these two
genes so this can be assessed to a hyper
geometric test and therefore a pure
synthetic lethality of course the above
group could be essentially also just
zero and but but but of course you have
loads of mutual exclusivity pairs in
tumor data ok you of course not all of
them will be synthetic lethal so what we
also imposed as a second criteria
criterion was that we wanted that the
individual mutations would be good or
neutral for tumors and bad or neutral
for patients and the both group not only
would be underrepresented but also bad
for tumors and good for patients and bad
for tumors this means yeah it's
synthetic this all right so they should
be worse off than having either of these
two genes mutated and then the then the
good and bad would be assessed with
patient survival and how was that
exactly done so we were plotting these
cap and Meyer plots for for the four
groups for than both g1 g2 and neither
which was treated in as a reference and
we were looking at the just the survival
function which is represented in the
kaplan-meier plot and to summarize these
these these survival functions we used
simply the area under these curves these
survival functions and this area under
these curves this is very natural right
so the the larger the area the more up
rd survival function is so the better
but of course this natural ways of
summary exists in insert in survival
analysis and that it even has a name
restricted mean lifetime this is simply
area under the survival curve so we were
computing these mini restricted
lifetimes for the three groups g1 g2 and
both because we wanted to compare them
so then the fitness of patients in any
of these three groups would be how well
they are doing in terms of their
survival as compared to the reference
and now we assumed okay we have to have
some proxy for the fitness of tumors
okay so that would be just the inverse
fitness of patients the weather the
tumor is go is is after the worst
patients are often dan dan the other way
around so then we had and then we
propose this SL score which would be
actually direct derivative of the of the
definition of a negative interaction so
this is the divergence from additive ax
t of the weaknesses right so we welcome
we had a ratio of the fitness of the
both group where both of them are
imitated and and what would be expected
from the individual frequencies there
was a log of fitness of both and the and
the ratio divided by the product of the
fitness's of the two groups so that's
course that score was used to rank our
candidate interaction pairs or synthetic
lethal interaction verse so the ones
that were on the top they were showing
this this largest sort of surprise in
terms of genetic interaction and then to
to assess significance of these into
actions we were using cox models which
were getting also taking into account
also the impact of other known
well-known predictions like age the
predictors like age or the other pages
okay so that was our work he saw work by
by by eight from athens group date and
I'm just showing you again a picture
from their paper because I just want to
say I just want to ask how well now can
we go in general in predicting this
synthetic lethality pairs and one way to
assess it is like like like they done in
this paper so you can basic try to try
to validate your predictions we have
experimentally verified gene pairs and
there they had synthetic lethal pairs
non-synthetic little interactions and
synthetic doses little altogether 7002
around 7,000 gene pers both positive and
negative cases and okay the day Z
approaches he is employed cuz like here
but in general it has the most important
component to the prediction are is
taking two sources of knowledge SOF
which is essentially mutual exclusivity
and co expression of genes okay so this
is how well you can do so a student of
mine hola Novak just wanted just to
focus on synthetic lethality so forget
about the synthetic doses lethality she
focused on SL only so that selected for
a that actually left on the 800 known
gene versus synthetic lethal gene first
and only 15 through positives to there's
much much much less true positives for
synthetic lethality than synthetic
dosage lethality and he tried to
replicate the daisy approach of course
as good as we could but in general i'm
actually pretty convinced that is it's
harder to predict synthetic aside and a
synthetic dosage lethality and the rest
room for improvement
synthetic lethality prediction so the
aucs is lower and in general synthetic
doses eyetality of course you could
better do better as well so we are
working on now at the moment is to
extend the evidence sources even more so
I believe in this in combining all these
data sources for improved predictions so
in particular we are looking we're
inspired by this paper by LOL we want to
look also at these volusia nary absence
presence patterns mine protein-protein
interaction networks and look for
specific motifs in these in these
networks which could predict negative
genetic interactions so with this I
would like to thank you very much for
your attention and I want to thank Nico
simona for the mutual exclusivity work
and navigate and Martin for the
synthetic lethality work and and Ola
Novak well who's working now on and on
this thank you very much questions so
you ra s else for that looked exactly
not what you would call at least a
season yes exactly so why does it
capture all the negative interactions
which is what you're looking for that
should also pick up positive ones I
think that there has to be some size so
it's one way or the the positive or
negative then do you would expect this
ratio to be sorry either larger or
negative smaller than zero than one
right so I'm working on in one direction
of course yes
ultimately the impact of of the genes
pairs that you choose the treatment
outcomes
so end in this in this work now I know
yeah absolutely in which of our models
in the it estimates the frequency of
mutations directly from the president it
exactly is estimated by taking the
frequency of mutation the likelihood in
this model is just computed as a as a
product of these frequencies on the Dean
of the gene across patients without
correcting for mutation rates pieces
without
yes can you generalize this court to no
more than two genes Hades yeah so I like
looking Riblet yeah I would have to
think first of a model of another model
of like an explanation what we find
surprising in the sense of what is
interaction between three like is it
only what you don't expect as additive
interaction between three and then
compare it to all of them or do you have
more you know the other aspects of this
combined interaction there could be
actually you know other things going on
between more than 21 right but maybe you
could
okay thank you very much thank you